the first task every state is to provide
security for its citizens so that is an
immediate challenge to all of us and the
Commission stands ready to help member
states to face that challenge where we
can but it's a we're not there to take
the competence that's up to member state
but we can be helpful
the European agenda on security provides
for a range of concrete actions the
creation of a center of excellence to
collect and share expertise on anti
radicalization an updated legal
framework on terrorism to deal with the
foreign fighters issue giving more
powers to financial intelligence units
to better track the financial dealings
of organized crime networks a revision
of the legal framework on firearms to
reduce access to weapons by criminals
and terrorists enhancing the
capabilities of Europol including
through the creation of a European
counter-terrorist Center within Europe
all the renewed EU internal security
strategy the new European agenda on
security should be a common agenda when
the security of our citizens their
rights our democratic values the
well-being of our societies and our
economy are at stake